c'est donc une situation exceptionnelle
qui frappe le pays la canicule qui dure
depuis plus d'une semaine maintenant
pourraient être à l'origine d'une
cinquantaine de décès en quatre jours en
ile de france
c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirme le
président de l'association des médecins
urgentistes hospitaliers
même si aucun bilan officiel n'existe
pour le moment stéphanie perez les
couloirs des urgences de l'hôpital
saint-antoine sont déjà submergés de
brancards et il n'est que 9 heures ce
matin principalement des personnes âgées
déshydraté déjà malade et que la
canicule affaiblit davantage une
situation catastrophique qui aurait
selon les médecins urgentistes provoqué
la mort de 50 personnes en quatre jours
à paris la direction générale de la
santé minimise et évoque l des morts
naturelles ce qui provoque la fureur de
ceux médecins débordés
oui tous malades finalement c'est une
cause naturelle et à quoi on sert ça
veut dire finalement va laisser ce
phénomène perdurer et on va pas
s'occuper des malades
mais qu'est ce qu'ils foutent de la
direction générale la santé il se moque
de qui le problème dit bien réelle c'est
que nous avons des malades qui sont en
train de mourir qui meurent peut-être
plutôt que ce qui devrait mais il
n'aurait pas dû mourir
difficile d'établir des statistiques
fiables
à propos des conséquences réelles de la
chaleur sur le nombre de décès mais la
situation est clairement exceptionnel
pas assez de lits pas assez de personnel
et un nombre d'admissions à paris qui a
presque doublé en quelques jours j'ai eu
un petit coup de chaleur guerre ces
dépenses sans jouer tu es assis sur un
banc rue faidherbe
il ya des passants qui ont voulu
absolument appeler les pompiers
énormément de gens
ou des personnes âgées parce qu'ils sont
déshydratés et qui se retrouve
effectivement avec une température
corporelle élevée aux ordres 38 autres
38 et 40 de fièvre et on sait pas où les
mettre
il faut les hospitaliser parce
qu'évidemment il faut les réhydrater et
actuellement ne sait pas où les mettre
parce qu'il n'ya pas de place n'est pas
pour l'association des médecins
urgentistes
il ne reste plus qu'une seule solution
envoyez le service de santé des armées à
la rescousse comme c'est déjà le cas ici
à orléans le seul moyen de rouvrir les
yeux
les autorités sanitaires accusé par les
médecins d'avoir sous-estimé la crise
étudie actuellement la question